Hey, Vsauce. Michael here,
and if you need more DONG
don't worry, because I'm bringing you
more things you could do online now, guys.
"JaydenMarkAnderson" recommended Clubcreate,
where you can make your own remixes right
inside your browser.
As we listen to a song I made this morning, check out
LYTRO. It's a camera that records a scene's entire
light field, so it can be refocused
after the fact. Just click
and see the results. On the simpler side,
"mynameizLachlan" brings us
Small Man Chases Cursor, which is exactly
that. "DYLZAL" keeps it real with
SelfControlFreak.com, where this guy
points
where you move your mouse and when you
move your mouse towards his face
swats it away. "CaptainFsh" showed us a
sweet way to calculate your age if you
lived on other planets.
Venus rotates on its axis so slowly that
even though I'd 41 Venus years old there,
I'd only be 38 Venus days old.
For some creativity
you've got to try Reimagine - The Game,
if you haven't already. "Dadakara100"
recommended it and every level
is a whole new box of weird fun. If you want to
slow things down and get dramatic like
"SillyFirecracker,"
use One Chance, a game where the world will
end in six days and you have to decide how
to spend it. I played the entire game
last night and it was incredibly
emotional, especially
because after I finished it
I checked out Dear Photograph,
a site where people take photos from
their childhood, revisit the locations
and hold the picture up to match.
Their messages and memories are amazing.
If zombie defense strategy is more
your style, check out "MrFishguy4"
four
and Rebuild,
a turn-based game where you organize land-use,
exploratory campaigns and cross your
fingers that you keep the survivors
alive and the human race
flourishing. Finally, YourFonts.com.
On this site you can download a template
to
write on and then scan and upload.
The site will turn your
own handwriting into your very own
computer font. Nice.
So there you go. A bunch of cool things
you can do online now guys.
Hey, great show, Michael.
Wait,
are you Kevin from Vsauce?
Yeah, how's it going?
It is fantastic to finally meet you face-to-face.
Hey, you too. What brings you here?
Well, I just wanted to announce a brand
new episode of Mind Blow over on
Vsauce2.
Right, right. Mind Blow on Vsauce2, because
we're finally giving both channels an
identity.
Yeah.
Vsauce is where I'm gonna be with funny
stuff, products and geeky pranks.
Yeah, and Vsauce2 is going to be full of
mind-blowing science,
facts and plenty of weirdos.
And riddles, right?
So go click right here to watch
Mind Blow on Vsauce2 if you haven't
already,
because, guys, it's a great thing to do online.
GDONG? Shhhhh.
As always,
thanks for watching.